all right it's Thursday so that means
it's time for another episode of Theory
Thursdays my new segment where you all
submit your theories for a chance to end
up in an episode I pick five each week
to review and talk about on the show you
all vote on which theory is your
favorite each week that theory enters
the pool of champions and then at the
end of the month out of all the theories
that won you all pick your favorite to
win the monthly prize if you would like
to enter your own theory for a chance to
end up in an episode you can find the
email and the directions in the
description down below
alright so let's dive into some theories
we have some really interesting ones
this week I'm excited to share them with
you the first one comes from - Hin Sinha
- Hin has some very interesting points
about Doctor Strange Wong and the time
stone in Avengers infinity war - Hin
says he picked up on a few things and
Avengers infinity war first is that when
Doctor Strange greets Tony he says
congrats on the wedding although it's
very clear that they're not married yet
Tony even invites Wang to his wedding
yet Doctor Strange doesn't say congrats
on your engagement he says congrats on
the wedding now this could just mean
congrats on your upcoming wedding but to
him has noticed a little bit more he
says that Wang just leaves Bruce Banner
in the middle of the street to go back
and guard the sanctum which is a little
suspicious why would want just casually
walk away when there's a threat to the
whole entire universe and he has vowed
to protect the time stone at all cost so
his theory is that when Banner arrived
at the sanctum dr. strange and Wang may
have looked forward in time to see
what's coming up and Doc may have asked
Wang to stay behind because he knew that
they were going to lose and Wang needs
to prepare for the next fight he says
that certainly with the time stone and
spells Doctor Strange can communicate
with Wang from anywhere and that's how
long comes into play in Avengers in game
I definitely think that this is possible
and we do know that Wang will be back in
Avengers in game we also know that the
ancient one will be back as well so
maybe there's some sort of a connection
with Wang dr. strange and the ancient
one and it actually makes a lot of sense
that dr. strange in Wang would look
forward in time if a threat as hugest
Thanos is coming and he's specifically
coming to collect the Infinity stones
which they are sworn to protect they'd
want to be prepared so maybe we'll find
out
that this actually happened in Avengers
endgame so that's theory number one on
to theory number two theory number two
comes from Aiden Jost and Aiden has a
theory about how Avengers and game is
going to go down Hayden's theory states
that the movie opens on ant-man in the
quantum realm fumbling with a quantum
particle container it slips from his
hands and falls into a time vortex
Scott reaches in and tries to grab it
but it's already gone Scott then decides
that he wants to get the heck out of the
quantum realm and puts a blue disc in
his generator growing back to normal
size as he grows back the pimp's family
ashes are flying away but he doesn't
even notice them he goes and he looks
for his family but he can't find them
anywhere so he goes to the Avengers
facility where Natasha and Steve tell
him everything about the decimation fast
forward a little bit into the movie Tony
nebula and Captain Marvel arrive and
ant-man tells them all about the time
vortex and they quickly come up with a
plan to stop Thanos from gathering all
of the Infinity stones Scott tells them
that they need special suits to go
inside of the quantum realm so Tony gets
working with Bruce nebula and Scott to
make the suits while Captain Marvel goes
and searches for Nick Fury but has no
look she does however find his pager and
realizes that he has been turned to dust
and heads back to the Avengers facility
The Avengers put on their new suits and
traveled down inside of the quantum
realm and go back to the decimation of
zan dark they fail to stop him from
getting the Power Stone they do however
stop him from completely destroying the
planet but in the process a nova officer
gets killed officer Alexander and before
he dies his final request was to have
his son take his place as Nova
ultimately the Avengers will stop Thanos
from getting the time soul and reality
stones but will fail to stop him from
getting the space and the power stone
they go to Wakanda for a final showdown
and the shot of the Avengers running
together in Wakanda from the infinity
war trailer is real they end up
defeating Thanos but Captain America and
Bucky end up getting seriously injured
and are both about to die but just then
the quantum healing container shows up
and Steve wants Bucky to take it saying
you're the new Captain America and then
Steve Rogers dies Tony Stark then goes
to the cliff where kill monger died and
he watches the sunset on a grateful
universe Aiden then says the end credits
scene will show Kang the Conqueror in
the quantum city watching The Avengers
discover the time vortex smiling all the
there are a lot of things in this theory
that make a lot of sense and I think
some people forget about the decimation
of xander being a big one I personally
think that they didn't show that
estimation of Zander and infinity war
because we're going to see it an in-game
and a lot of people think that ant-man
is just going to jump inside of a time
vortex right away to get out but he
could probably get out the same way he
got out in the first ant-man movie but I
do think he will see a time vortex and
will ultimately tell the Avengers about
it and Bucky Barnes will most likely be
the next Captain America it happens in
the comics and he is a super soldier and
he is Captain America's best friend so
that does it for Theory 2 on to number
three number three comes from Lois and
Justin in Las Vegas with a theory on the
second mold that we saw in edible ear
they think that the second mold that we
saw could be a shield for Captain
America we know from what Mark Ruffalo
said that Bruce Banner and rocket are
going to go off on an adventure together
so Thor's going to need a new adventure
buddy maybe him and Captain America go
back to Ned oval ear to forge a new
weapon we've already seen Captain
America move mule near what if the new
shield made out of arune metal operates
the same way that mule near and
Stormbreaker do operating on sheer will
instead of the traditional magnetism
that caps shield uses to return so he
could throw it and control it just like
Thor does with mule near and
Stormbreaker
this could be why captain is shaking in
the trailer as he straps on the shield
because he's harnessing the power of the
shield this is an awesome theory because
I would love if Captain America could
get a room metal shield this sort of
happens in the fear itself' Comics The
Avengers go to Ned of Lear and they
throw their weapons into a vat of molten
Aroo turning their weapons into goo and
making them vastly stronger this makes
sense because obviously Thor knows that
Stormbreaker was strong enough to defeat
Thanos in theory so why wouldn't they go
back to neduvaali R to get more weapons
like Stormbreaker and of course if that
happened the weapon that Captain America
would get would be a shield so that's
number three on to number four number
four comes from Jason ziz kind and jason
has a theory about how dr. strange may
have used the time stone to save Tony
Stark and possibly ant-man with Captain
Marvel jason says that as you know
Doctor Strange went forward in time and
saw 14 million 605 different scenarios
in which the
vengers only one one Jason's theory is
that dr. strange used the time stone to
go back to the 1990s and told Nick Fury
when to use the pager and when to
contact Captain Marvel this would
explain why Steven strange was under
file as a threat to Hydra and Captain
America the Winter Soldier he could have
told Nick what was going to happen on
the day of the decimation and where Tony
Stark would be and that it was up to
Captain Marvel to rescue him she could
also save ant-man in the quantum realm
because that is most likely where she
gets her powers from in the MCU that
would also add up with why Samuel
Jackson said in an interview that
Captain Marvel was able to time-travel
she may be in another century so that's
why it would take time to save Tony
Stark on the Benatar specifically three
days where he runs out of food and water
strange could have also done similar
things to protect different universes
which could introduce the x-men and
Fantastic Four because he was referenced
in San Rama's spider-man - this is
certainly possible in fact why wouldn't
Doctor Strange do this if Doctor Strange
saw the one only outcome in which the
Avengers went it would make sense that
Doctor Strange would manipulate events
in time to make this happen
in fact he's really the only person that
can with the time stone and I can see in
Avengers endgame Captain Marvel showing
up to save Tony telling Tony yeah
Nick Fury told me that you would be in
this exact spot over 20 years ago
so that's theory number 4 on to the
final theory number 5 number 5 comes
from Cody Mashburn and he thinks that
dr. strange will use a relic that was
mentioned in Avengers infinity war the
cauldron of the cosmos he thinks that
dr. strange will use the cauldron of the
cosmos to look back in time to assist
with when and where to go in time in the
universe he also thinks that Ant Man
could end up getting help from the
people inside of the quantum realm that
live inside of the quantum city this
could be something so subtle but so
important because I do think it was
mentioned for a reason other than comedy
in Avengers infinity war the cauldron of
the cosmos is a really strong relic fact
Doctor Strange could have definitely
used to help the outcome of avengers
endgame I've thought this before and I
definitely do not think that Marvel does
anything unintentionally I do think that
it was mentioned for a reason and it
could end up being a part of Avengers
and game so that does it for this week's
theories let's do a quick
cap theory number one is that dr.
strange had Wong go back to the sanctum
to prepare for the next fight because
him and dr. strange looked forward in
time number two is how Avengers endgame
is going to go down the Avengers time
travel back twos and art and they keep
Thanos from getting a few of the stones
at the end Captain America dies Bucky
becomes the new Captain America and Tony
watches the Sun rise on a grateful
universe number three is that Captain
America and Thor will travel back to
neduvaali R and Captain America will get
a shield made out of room metal number
four is that Doctor Strange actually
saves Tony Stark by going back in time
and telling Nick Fury and Captain Marvel
where Tony will be stranded and number
five is that Doctor Strange
uses the cauldron of the cosmos and that
ant-man will get help from the people
inside of the quantum realm in the
quantum city so those are this week's
theories be sure to vote on which one
you like the most and again if you would
like to enter your own theory for a
chance to end up on a segment of Theory
Thursdays you can find the email and the
directions in the description down below
and of course if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on every Theory Thursday
and all Marvel related news as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]